I think people have always been really
interested in how birds fly and
particularly birds are flying a
v-formation
and it's simply because you look up to
the sky and you see these birds and this
such an organized state that you
instantly go how are they doing that why
they're doing it
there's been so many theories put
forward so far to try and explain why
birds flying these distinctive V
formations and these theories range from
a traditional the more birds the better
the predator comes along picks one off
it's not going to be me there's an idea
that the birds at the front might be
better navigators and another one that's
really persisted as this idea of as an
energetic benefit to flying in a V
formation that for those birds flying at
the back they're not having to work as
hard during the flight
the main study so far that shows that
birds can get an energetic benefit from
flying in a V formation as a classic
nature paper for about ten years ago and
they're looking at pelicans flying
across a lake and what they found was
the bird at the front had a much higher
heart rate than the rest of the birds in
the V and they were using heart rate as
a proxy for energy expenditure so that
was the first real empirical evidence
that there might be some truth to this
sort of long-standing idea as an
energetic benefit to being in a
v-formation we were lucky enough to work
with a conservation group based in
Austria who are trying to reintroduce
this critically endangered bird called
northern bull divers back into his
former range in the Alps and they do
that by hatching the eggs onto human
foster parents and the foster parents
then spend all spring and summer with
these birds who become habituated and
imprinted on them and then they have
these birds following a microlight
containing these foster parents who are
constantly calling out to the birds
follow us follow us and the birds follow
this microlight and they learn what
should be their correct migration route
to their wintering grounds
so far it's been very difficult to study
flight in free flying birds because if
you start to put equipment on them and
then they fly off into the distance the
chances are you're not going to see that
equipment again you need to get that
equipment back to get the information
off it for many years we've been working
towards creating these loggers are able
to measure where an animal is and what
it's doing there so whether it was
flapping how hard was it flapping how
fast was it going when you start to put
all this together you can really start
to investigate the mechanisms and the
interactions that are going on between
individuals within the flock so these
are the loggers that we were developing
in our lab that went on the birds you
can see here they have quite a large
battery which is essential for the quite
long sampling periods this antenna here
receives the GPS information it doesn't
emit it and that's what made this such a
good collaboration because these birds
would been flown and then returning home
at the end of the day so if you get the
logger off and get the data off it to
the bird start of training for that
migration around June July and they have
these little local training flights
whether it's learning how to fly how to
fly as a group and also to make sure
they follow the microlight
and then towards the end of the summer
kind of late August the actual full
migration begins and this migration
takes them from Salzburg in Austria
right round to southern Italy but to
avoid the Alps which might be a little
bit problematic for the young bird we
take a slightly convoluted journey
through Austria right round flew
souvenir and then down into Italy when
the birds take off it takes them around
four to five minutes to sort of
orientate themselves into this
traditional v-shape for they kind of
start heading off
the first really interesting result that
we got off the loggers was that the
birds were locating themselves in
positions within the V formation that
was completely predicted by fixed-wing
aerodynamics and what we mean by that is
they were positioning themselves in the
best possible spot to take advantage of
the good air the upwash coming off the
bird in front so the aromatics behind
yov might make sense goes like this if
you have a bird flapping along it has to
throw air down in order for it to stay
up this means that instead of the air
building up at the bottom or on the
ground
it squeezes around the edge at which
point you've got the circulation of air
that looks like this so it got downwash
here but upwash here which means the
bird flapping along here could fly in
effectively upwards moving air and so it
doesn't have a flaps are harder to stay
on and then if you add that another bird
then you get a half a v-formation to it
both sides and got a v-formation tagging
up so even though the birds fitted
fixed-wing aerodynamics where they
position themselves we can't ignore the
fact they were flapping and in fact this
is where the most interesting result was
and what they're doing with their
flapping and when they're flapping along
and what we totally weren't expecting
was that they might be paying attention
to the flat phasing of the bird ahead so
if you're flapping then this this up was
the river this whirl of air behind you
is going up and down up and down with
your wings but both of the really neat
thing is we could show that if this one
is a whole wavelength ahead then this
one flaps in phase so that that wingtip
path which is this winter
and if it's half a wavelength behind
then they flat like that which means
that wingtip path is still matching that
way to path
the implications of this research could
be quite far-reaching so for example
airlines have been investing heavily to
try and understand how birds can get so
close together to take advantage of as
upwash they want their planes doing the
same thing of course something the birds
have been doing forever and just do
intuitively
you
you